richard où elle est et spécialiste du
droit international économique à
l'université laval bonsoir richard
ouellette
bonsoir on va commencer avec emmanuel
macron est-ce que la menace du président
macro et sérieuse est ce que ça pourrait
compromettre vraiment l'accord de libre
échange avec l'union européenne
évidemment ça reste une prise de
position mais je ne pense pas qu'il
faille s'alarmer de cette prise de
position la mettons la en contexte on
est au lendemain d'élections municipales
en france où le parti du manuel match on
a perdu de nombreuses importantes mairie
aux mains des groupes verts
donc il était dans le temps de faire
cette déclaration là de toute façon la
france
effectivement ne ratifierait pas d
accord qu il irait complètement à
l'encontre de l'accord de paris mais
disons bien que le cg et peuvent des
accords les plus verts que l'union
européenne est signé ces dernières
années alors si on ne veut pas de leur
sujet il y à bien des accords de libre
échange dans l'union européenne devrait
se départir
nous allons aussi sur la somme l'accord
de libre-échange avec les états-unis le
mexique qui va entrer en vigueur la
cette semaine mercredi comment expliquer
que les etats unis puissent encore
menacé d'imposer des tarifs douaniers
sur l'aluminium au moment où le nouvel
alena entre en vigueur
les etats unis se classent un petit peu
en mode panique et là encore une mise en
contexte politique s'impose on est en
année électorale aux états unis et
l'administration trump cherche à montrer
qu'elle veut le protégera les emplois
dans des secteurs qui sont fragiles il
est vrai que les exportations
canadiennes vers les états unis ont
augmenté
quand on voit par mois pour moi les
exportations de cette année avec celle
de l'année passée est dorénavant on le
sait un mécanisme de suivi qui permet de
bien montrer ces chiffres là par contre
le canada effectivement ne causent pas
de dommage à l'économie américaine
les américains ont grand besoin de
l'aluminium canadien donc si les états
unis pensent que c'est un bon moment
pour appliquer des des droits de douane
pour des raisons peut-être plus
politique qu'économique
ils se trompent et le premier ministre
eu d'eau dans sa déclaration
d'aujourd'hui je pense
avait plutôt raison les chiffres sont
têtus et on constate bien donné à
l'appui que les amis et ont besoin de
l'aluminium canadien pour quantité
d'industrie où ils ont besoin de cet
aluminium pour la transformation mais
expliquez nous le rapport avec la
finesse que les américains soupçonnent
que l'aluminium canadien provient de la
fine c'est toujours en trame de fond
sont les états unis continuent de
soupçonner que la chine par toutes
sortes de biens fait entrer de son
aluminium qu'elle sur produit il faut
bien le dire la chaîne sur produit
énormément de l'aluminium qu'elle fasse
pas assez c'est aluminium par le mexique
par le canada pour qu'ensuite cet
aluminium soit soient transformés et
soit exporté telquel vers le marché
américain
et ça c'est toujours une crise ça fait
toujours partie de l'écran radar des
états unis at il analyse le marché de
l'aluminium et de l'acier les producteur
américain d'aluminium se le dit ne font
pas tous d'accord
n'est ce pas pour qui a des tarifs
douaniers comme ça que sont imposés à
l'industrie canadienne absolument à
l'industrie divisée on sait que ce sont
deux entreprises qui sont qui se font
beaucoup pour rendre ces temps-ci
magnitude savez nous 7 et century
aluminium qui sont qui ont un discours
qui a ses répercussions sur les discours
même du représentant américain au
commerce
robert lauri tyson mais d'autres
entreprises comme rio tinto comme alcoa
ne sont pas d'avis que le canada a trop
exporter de l'ue minium sur le
territoire américain et ne sont pas
favorables à la prise de tarifs
douaniers punitifs contre l'allier
l'aluminium canadien donc l'industrie
diviser le monde des affaires n'est pas
particulièrement friands de cette prise
de mesures là et si l'administration
troque le fait pour des raisons
politiques en pensant consolider
certains voient elle va certainement
aussi irrité en nombre
d'entreprise et une bonne partie de la
communauté d'affaires aux états unis
qu'est ce qui va arriver là c'est les
états unis appliquent cette semaine à
nouveau des tarifs douaniers
il va falloir se battre il va falloir
réactive et évidemment tout ce que les
accords prévoient entre nous pour voir
dans quelle mesure est ce qu'ils avaient
raison d'appliquer ces mesures là la
rumeur veut aujourd'hui que ces nouveaux
tarifs douaniers soit appliquée en vertu
de l'article 232 de la loi sur le
commerce international aux états unis ce
fameux article 232 les gens en ont
entendu parler depuis deux ans
c'est l'article par lequel les
etats-unis évoquent leur sécurité
nationale pour restreindre l'entrée de
l'aluminium aux états unis et ça c'est
difficile à arbitrer cet argument là
parce que ça à partie un peu aux états
donc il va falloir encore une fois faire
preuve de diplomatie de patience et
négocier avec les américains
un peu comme si on avait pas d'accord
finalement parce que c'est comme ça
qu'il faut le prendre pour s'assurer
d'une bonne entrée d'un bon accès de
notre aluminium sur le marché américain
qu'est ce qui va changer qu'est-ce que
vous surveillez mercredi avec
l'application de la ferme qui entre en
vigueur
il va falloir voir dans quelle avec quel
ton quel état d'esprit on applique ce
nouvel accord là on attendait en fin de
semaine
robert lay parisien encore une fois dire
qu'il allait appliquer de façon très
stricte et à la lettre l'accord pour
protéger les intérêts américains
il faudrait qu'un accord comme celui là
soit plutôt vu comme un échange
économique comme de bonnes relations
comme quelque chose qui permet
d'intégrer nos marchés ce n'est pas tout
à fait dans cet esprit là que les états
unis je pense vont appliquer l'accord au
départ et il faudra donc accès mire le
ton l'apaiser pour s'assurer que les
entrées sur le marché américain que nous
avons négociés dans cet accord ne soit
effectivement donné et là c'est un
nouvel accord très régional on n'est pas
dans le les accords à plusieurs c'est
l'accord du président trompe c'est un
accord que le président de rome ont
exigé
on sait que ni le canada du mexique ni
les administrations américaines
précédentes ne demandait la
renégociation de l'alena
il a été demandé
elle a été demandée cette renégociation
par l'administration from
l'administration trump il ya intégré
beaucoup de petites mesures qui
permettent de contrôler les choses on
aime avoir le contrôle sur les flux de
commerce
on ne veut pas nécessairement aplanir
les barrières au commerce et laisser les
marchés se faire
on souhaite surtout savoir combien de
l'est vendredi vous à quelle condition
allez vous produire les pièces
automobiles quel salaire donnerez-vous
aux travailleurs chez vous qu'est ce que
vous allez exporté en termes de produits
laitiers comment allez vous traitez les
hommes les marchandises qui entrent
après une transaction en ligne
il y à davantage de contrôles on est
davantage dans ce qu'on appelle le
commerce géré que dans le libre échange
qui donne de très épais accord en termes
de nombre de feuilles
merci les charrois l'aip merci beaucoup
ça me fait grand plaisir